Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Weißt du eigentlich was das Higgs Boson macht?
Es verleiht dieser Sendung mehr Gewicht.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 458 vom 28.
April 2023 logbuchnetzpolitik das standardmodell.
Standardmodell der Netzpolitik. Das Higgs boson.
Zerlegen hier alles in Welle und Teilchen bis nichts mehr übrig bleibt.
Du warst doch da wo die so ein Higgs boson mal gefunden haben.
CERN. CERN. Da war ich gerade. Da komme ich gerade von zurück.
Schön. Haben sie dir ihr Higgs-Boson gezeigt oder haben die das da ausgestellt oder was war die da?
Naja also indirekt schon oder haben die das schon wieder verlegt.
Man ey, ganze Anlage gebaut um eins und Higgsboson und jetzt scheiße.
Das ist in der Tat auch nicht lange geblieben. Das ist sofort kaputt gegangen. Wie die SpaceX Rakete.
Aber Erfolg, also wir haben, eigentlich ist der Tresor jetzt offen.
Das ist da generell das Ding, also so Kollisionen, Explosionen und wenn die
Dinge dann gleich wieder verschwinden, das gehört dazu. Die wissen einfach was
danach passiert und wenn das passiert dann sind sie glücklich.
Wir machen Sachen kaputt damit wir wissen, dass es sie mal gab.
So könnte man es auch umschreiben, ganz schön. Ja, aber es ist ein schöner Nerdhaufen
da unten und ich habe da einen Podcast-Marathon.
Hingelegt. Das war ganz schön anstrengend.
42 Folgen?
Naja so viele waren es dann nicht aber ich habe zwei Tage durchpodcast,
ich würde sagen so sechs Sendungen in zwei Tagen gemacht.
Also drei pro Tag.
Sechs Sendungen wie der Holgi.
Ja so richtige Sendungen mit Inhalt.
Gibt es dann demnächst bei Raumzeit.
Und wo die Leute am Ende noch leben. Weil heute sind ja alle am Ende tot.
Ja ist das so?
Na wir hören ja oft zu reden.
So stimmt. Den Aspekt habe ich noch gar nicht verleugt.
Ich habe alle wieder lebendig entlassen. Das war überhaupt kein Problem.
Und das waren dann so Teilchenbeschleuniger, waren das dann da?
Genau, das waren alle hauptberufliche Teilchenbeschleuniger,
die nimmt man besser mal nicht mit zum Bäcker.
Ja ok, willst du noch was davon erzählen?
Was interessiert dich denn?
Wie groß, wie war es, was trinken die zum Mittag?
Also das sind eigentlich normale Leute, aber es ist einfach Nerd Heaven,
also es ist einfach, ich meine da arbeiten, da sind irgendwie ne fünfstellige Zahl von Leuten,
die da irgendwie Wissenschaft betreiben, davon irgendwie zweieinhalb tausend
oder so hauptamtlich und bauen da einfach krasse Scheiße in die Erde,
die haben da irgendwie einen super Large Hadron Collider, so einen 27 Kilometer
langen Tunnel, wo sie da halt einfach ihre Teilchen final beschleunigen,
100 Meter unter der Erde.
Ist der lang? Ist das nicht ein Kreis?
Ja, 27 Kilometer ist der lang. Der Kreis.
Kreise haben Umfang. und gelten als unendlich.
Kann man so sehen, man kann natürlich auch mit dem Kuhschreiber kurz an der
Wand notieren, wo man angefangen hat und weiß, dass man immer wieder an der gleichen Stelle ist.
Ja ja, naja es sind so mehrere Ringe tatsächlich, die werden dann immer länger
und immer größer, die bauen halt sozusagen immer wieder noch einen größeren,
der dann von den anderen versorgt wird, damit es noch schneller wird.
Also da ist wirklich bigger is better und denen kann es gar nicht schnell genug
sein. Da geht es einfach darum möglichst viel Energie von französischen Atomkraftwerken zu verberaten.
Warum soll man nicht zeigen wenn es einem gut geht.
Ein riesiger Kühlschrank ist das da sozusagen.
So wo kann man das hören? Wir sind jetzt hier im Empfehlungenteil.
Gibt's wie gesagt demnächst? Bei Raumzeit. Bei Raumzeit. Raumzeit Podcast.
Genau. Der Podcast für Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Wie es so schön heißt.
Dann haben wir noch eine weitere Empfehlung. Und zwar. Ja. Der Spion in unseren Handys.
Ein Podcast von Zeit Online. Erste Folge war mit hier Kai Biermann,
also er war früher mal bei Zeit Digital,
jetzt ist er im Investigator Team da bei der Zeit,
die haben sich mit Pegasus auseinandergesetzt, also dem Handy Trojaner der NSO Group.
Ich glaub die ersten beiden Folgen hab ich jetzt gehört, war, also ist gut, ja?
Es ist natürlich so ein bisschen, die müssen ja dann sehr, immer sehr gut um
Metaphern und Vergleiche bemüht, um dieses Abhörsystem irgendwie,
ja in seiner, in seinem Einschnitt in das Telefon zu beschreiben und abzubilden
das ist natürlich teilweise dann ja nicht mehr so nah an der Technik,
klingt dann wieder so ein bisschen sehr nach den übermächtigen Cyberwaffe und
Wunderhacker und sowas ja aber das lässt sich ja auch auf eine Weise nicht vermeiden
und ist ja auch gewissermaßen richtig,
dass das eben die, Oder nicht gewissermaßen, aber es ist die übelste,
bekannte Spionagesoftware für Mobiltelefone, die nur enorm wenige Spuren hinterlässt
und enorm tiefen Eingriff in das System ermöglicht. Also es ist ja schon alles korrekt.
Ich persönlich hätte es mir technisch noch spannender vorgestellt.
Aber es ist super erzählt und es setzt sich halt mit der NSO Group auseinander,
welche Leute dieses Ding, dieses Unternehmen gegründet haben,
wie sich das dann so entwickelt und so sehr interessant.
Ich glaub die haben gesagt es sind sechs Folgen oder so.
Tauchst du da auch drin vor?
Weiß ich nicht, bisher nicht.
Bisher nicht, okay. Also es gibt bisher drei Folgen.
Ja ich hab's noch nicht zu Ende gehört, deswegen weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube es werden sechs oder so und ich hab's nicht so im Kopf,
dass es sechs Folgen werden oder so.
Ja ist auf jeden Fall ganz spannend.
Das ist so ein Prinzip so ein bisschen, finde ich eine interessante Idee,
so dieses Konzept von Serial, irgendwie wir erzählen jetzt mal hier so eine konsequente,
eine Geschichte konsequent, also ob es dann wirklich konsequent ist kann ich
natürlich nicht beurteilen, aber
das ist ja sozusagen Podcast so als Erzählformat, würde ich mal sagen.
Das ist das Konzept. Ja, ja, weil es ja nicht,
also wer kann schon sagen was ist ein Podcast so,
aber wie wir ja wissen ist ja schon so im wesentlichen das Merkmal Podcast ist
wenn zwei weiße Männer sich unterhalten über das was sie betrifft.
Wo sie jeweils recht haben.
Ja genau, das ist ein Podcast.
Die gegenseitig was erklären.
Und sich auf die Schulter klopfen.
Und dann ist das einer, das ist ein Podcast.
Aber ab und zu macht man es auch mal anders, dann hat man halt mehr Männer und
doch eine Frau dazu und dann hast du ein anderes Konzept.
Als Erzählformat hast du schon recht, die erzählen eine Geschichte von vorne
nach hinten, das ist auch ganz gut.
Dann wollte ich noch was empfehlen und zwar habe ich irgendwo ist das an mir
vorbeigescrollt, dass Marco Buschmann, der Justizminister, 3000 Follower auf Soundcloud hat.
Er ist DJ, ne?
Und deswegen wollte ich empfehlen, auf Soundcloud Junkelmusik zu folgen, weil...
Nicht Marco Buschmann.
Ne, der hat ja schon 3000 Follower.
Ja und du nicht oder was?
Und das kann ich so ja natürlich nicht auf mir sitzen lassen.
Der Typ ist schon Justizminister, der kann jetzt nicht auch noch der Soundcloud-King da sein.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich mir das einmal angehört, was der da gemacht hat,
war da jetzt noch nicht so davon überzeugt.
Außerdem wollen wir uns bei ein paar Festivals bewerben und dafür brauchen wir mehr Klicks.
Ganz einfach.
Du fragst einfach frech nach Followern und willst einfach mehr Social Media
Präsenz haben und nutzt dazu einfach existierende Kandidaten,
die damit eigentlich nichts zu tun haben.
Habe ich mir jetzt mal so gedacht.
Ja, so macht man das. Habe ich gehört.
Dann nehmen wir, dann habe ich eine Verlosung.
Wir haben eine Verlosung und zwar haben wir Post bekommen, sehr liebe Post von der Susanne.
Die Susanne hat die bei uns im Meta-Ebene-Shop erhältlichen Raumbildenden Packmittel
Raumbildenden Packmittel gekauft und dann umgebaut, umgenäht.
Und zwar haben sie keine Tragegriffe mehr,
sondern nun eine Form, die geeignet ist, beispielsweise einen tragbaren Computer darin aufzubewahren.
Das heißt rein technisch rechtlich ist es kein Tragebeutel mehr,
ist aber nach wie vor dazu gedacht, was zu tragen.
Es ist also immer noch ein,
raumbildendes Packmittel, allerdings nicht ein Tragebeutel und wir haben da
mal ein Foto von in der Sendungsbeschreibung, wie heißt das,
in den Shownotes und wer uns in den Kommentaren erklären kann, was das denn jetzt ist.
Und es haben möchte.
Und es haben möchte. Da haben wir zwei und ich würde sagen, die ersten beiden.
Guten Erklärung werden Beschreibung was und was es sich hierbei handelt,
die können dann sollen und mit einer erreichbaren E-Mail Adresse, weil sonst können wir.
Die nicht veröffentlicht werden muss aber in den Kommentaren.
Genau die wird nicht veröffentlicht aber die muss in den Kommentaren,
das Feld wird nicht veröffentlicht und dann können wir euch schreiben und dann
sagt ihr uns die Adresse und dann kriegt ihr diese Objekte.
Jetzt können wir aber gar nicht sagen, warum wir die nicht selber verwenden können.
Unsere tragbaren Rechner sind zu klein.
Willst du uns verraten, was es ist?
Habe ich gerade schon gesagt.
Die Suche ist ja nach der korrekten Beschreibung.
Nicht der landläufigen.
Achso.
Landläufig ist ja völlig klar, was das ist. Aber das wäre ja zu einfach.
Also es muss sozusagen mit deutschen DIN-Normen auch konform sein.
Das sollte zumindest deutschen DIN-Normen nicht im Widerspruch stehen, die Bezeichnung.
Weil unsere tragbaren Rechengeräte passen da nicht rein oder nicht gut rein
und deswegen sind wir uns sicher, dass sich Leute darüber freuen werden.
Es ist ein schönes Werk und man sieht das Einhorn drauf. Und es ist handgemacht von Susanne.
Vielen herzlichen Dank. Also das Foto könnt ihr in den Show Notes sehen und
wenn ihr sowas euer eigen nennen wollt, müssen wir uns nur sagen was es ist.
Und gewisse Kreativität an den Tag legen.
Das ist setz dich voraus.
Ja, ich weiß. Aber ich betone das nochmal, dass du das voraussetzt.
Und bitte E-Mail Adresse. Okay. Kommen wir zum Feedback. Mhm.
Ähm, Stefan?
Hat Kommentiert Hallo zusammen in eurer letzten Sendung habt ihr darüber spekuliert,
dass es irgendwann freie Alternativen zu ChatGPT geben wird Ich glaube ihr nannt
es WikipediaGPT Es gibt einige Projekte in diese Richtung,
das am weitesten fortgeschritten und ideologisch kompatibelste für mich ist
OpenAssistant unter open-assistant.io.
Das Projekt macht drei Dinge. Sie trainieren eigene, freie Sprachmodelle und
bieten eine erste Version eines eigenen Chatassistenten auf Ihrer Webseite an,
der auf Englisch schon ganz passable Antworten gibt.
Sie sammeln freie Datensätze aus den verschiedensten Quellen und bauen Skripte
zur Aufbereitung der verschiedenen Daten, um damit einen Sprachassistenten trainieren zu können.
Wenn jemand auf Dialogdaten aus alten AI-Programmen oder der Sozialforschung
herumsitzt, Spenden sind immer willkommen.
Drittens, sie bauen einen eigenen freien mehrsprachigen Dialogdatensatz auf,
mit dem man Modelle trainieren kann. Da verbieten sie eine Web-Oberfläche,
in der du Dialoge schreiben und klassifizieren kannst. Auch hier sind Helfende immer gern gesehen.
Der deutsche Datensatz könnte noch mehr Input und vielfältigere Themen vertragen.
Das Projekt ist noch ganz am Anfang, es gibt viele offene Fragen,
aber das ist ja bei allen AI-Themen im Moment so.
Das also mal zu sehen. Also hier gibt's dann Open Assistant Conversational AI for Everyone.
We believe we can create a revolution.
Dann gab's noch einen Kommentar von Sebastian, den ich recht spannend fand,
Weil ich ja gesagt habe, dass es besonders teuer wäre, solche Modelle zu trainieren
und ich habe dabei den Begriff Milliarden verwendet.
Und dann sagt Sebastian, hallo Linus, zum Thema Trainingskosten für Chet, GPT3 und Co.
Es kostet nicht Milliarden, sondern bald nicht mal mehr 100.000.
Von daher kann sich bald jede Unistadt, jeder größere Verein oder Firma das
Training einer eigenen KI leisten.
Daher ist wohl eher davon auszugehen, dass Google sein Suchmonopol verlieren wird.
Er zitiert, according to the ARC Invest Big Ideas 2023 report,
training costs of a large language model similar to GPT-3 level performance have plummeted from 4.6,
million in 2020 to 450.000 in 2022, a decline of 70 percent per year.
Irre, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass dieser preisliche Verfall so rapide wäre.
Allerdings glaube ich, hier ist dann wahrscheinlich nur die Computing-Wärme
mit drin und die Aufbereitung der Daten ist ja sicherlich auch ein nicht zu
vernachlässigender Teil davon,
der ja hier im ersten Kommentar von Stefan auch noch mehr gewürdigt wird.
Ist aber tatsächlich auf jeden Fall in ganz anderen Größenordnungen,
als ich dachte, ich glaube es ist aber trotzdem nicht davon auszugehen,
dass hier demnächst jeder mal eben sagt, ich mach mal eben eine AI fertig,
AI Knopf an einer Tastatur oder so, das wird nicht passieren,
weil wir einfach nicht die ordentlichen Daten dafür haben werden,
also Trainingsdatensätze werden dann das Problem sein.
Deswegen auch die beiden Kommentare hier, Stefan und Sebastian.
Also nicht nur, also das auch. Also erstmal muss ich dazu sagen,
das bezieht sich auf Chat GPT 3.
So wir sind jetzt bei 4 und da war auch noch ein 3,5 dazwischen und nicht der einzige,
aber ein wesentlicher Aspekt der sehr viel ausgeprägteren Leistungsfähigkeit
dieser Large Language Models ist der, dass das Untertitel der Amara.org-Community,
Datenvolumen was da herangezogen wurde um so ein
Modell aufzubauen nochmal signifikant viel viel viel größer war das heißt ein
bisschen sinnlos darüber nachzudenken was Aufwand man jetzt für die Größenordnung
3 bräuchte wenn im Prinzip die Größenordnung von einem 4 und vielleicht auch
einem 5 die nochmal sehr viel weiter oben liegen kommt.
Also das ist, ich glaube das ist natürlich ein großer Punkt,
also wenn es billiger wird diese Modelle zu trainieren, auf dem Niveau bedeutet
das, es werden bessere gemacht. Das heißt nicht, dass es billiger wird,
sondern es wird einfach besser.
Also das ist ja genauso wie, also die Computing Power,
die wir haben, in jetzt zum Beispiel, ich guck jetzt gerade hier so auf so einen M2 Mac Apple,
das sind Wahnsinns Prozessor, aber das dauert nicht lange, bis du genug Idioten
findest, die Software schreiben, um auch diesen Computer an seine Grenze zu
bringen, ja und zwar ohne, dass ich dem jetzt großartig was abverlange.
Also Computing Power, die zur Verfügung steht, die wird ja dann eben auch genutzt
und nicht genügsam gesagt, ach Mensch toll, guck mal wir können jetzt alles
sehr viel schneller machen, sondern die Computer werden halt ausgemaxed, das ist dein Argument.
Das heißt, man wird jetzt nicht sagen, ach geil, wir können alle mit Chachi
PT3 uns zufriedengeben, sondern dann wird eben 5, 6 und so weiter,
wird weiterhin Millionen kosten, weil sie Millionen ausgeben und dafür einfach
bessere Modelle kriegen.
Ja also ich glaube einfach, dass es generell etwas schwierig ist solche Zahlen
überhaupt zu generieren, weil du letzten Endes, du brauchst auf jeden Fall auch
erst mal Kompetenz und ich glaube, dass die Personalkosten in diesem ganzen
Zusammenhang jetzt auch nicht ganz unwichtig sind.
Derzeit kannst du ja, kannst du jetzt bei Chachibity, kannst du halt für 20
Dollar im Monat, kannst du sagen so hier, gib mal.
Und das neueste Modell, das Vierer, was wirklich viel besser ist als das Vorläufer
Modell, Da gibt es ein Rate Limiting. Du kannst halt gerade mal 25 Anfragen
stellen innerhalb von drei Stunden.
Das wird natürlich demnächst dann auch wegfallen, aber das hat eben sehr viel
damit zu tun, dass der Abfrageaufwand noch sehr viel größer ist.
Das heißt in dem Moment wo so ein System auch wirklich populär wird und wo es
auch wirklich Geld erzeugen soll, dann musst du nochmal sehr viel mehr Ressourcen
für die Abfrage dieses Modells bereitstellen, weil das eben auch eine krasse Tätigkeit ist.
Das ist nicht mal runtergerechnet und dann kann so jeder PC das mal so eben
machen, sondern da gehört eben auch nochmal eine ganze Menge dazu.
Ich bin so ein bisschen skeptisch bei diesen Zahlen, klar Milchmädchenrechnung
ist so ein bisschen dieses wird schon alles irgendwie billiger werden,
klar aber die Frage ist welcher Aspekt das erzeugen des Modells oder eben das
abfragen dieses Modells, wie schnell geht das.
Was wir sicherlich sehen werden auf dieser Strecke ist so ein bisschen auch
so AI as a Service also dass du dann sozusagen deine Sub-AIs quasi auf dem Hauptsystem verankerst,
spezialisierte Abfragesysteme quasi nochmal sozusagen als Oberschicht machst.
Man kann ja auch derzeit, man kann ja auch zum Beispiel schlechten AIs Beine
machen durch die besseren AIs,
also Siri zum Beispiel taugt ja gar nix, aber du kannst halt Chat-GPT fragen
wie man Siri richtig fragt damit es auch ordentliche Antworten gibt, so ne Sachen.
Und derzeit haben wir es ja auch mit sehr viel Meta-Entwicklungen zu tun, so Auto-GPT etc.
Also derzeit ist so dieses AI on top of AI on top of AI auch nochmal so ein Ding und derzeit.
Strecken alle ihre Fühler aus, was jetzt irgendwie geht und alles wird mit allem kombiniert werden.
Also ich glaube die Kosten an sich werden explodieren, aber es wird auch eine
sehr große Nachfrage geben, weil im Gegensatz zu diesem ganzen Krypto Quatsch
ist halt hier auch wirklich Value drin. Man weiß bloß noch nicht ganz genau
wo, aber der ist auf jeden Fall drin.
Also ich arbeite da gerade mit einem Arbeitskollegen an einem Vortrag zu dem Thema.
Der ist meist, wie nennt man das,
Doktor des maschinellen Lernens oder so, du wisstest wahrscheinlich was das ist.
Und dann denkt das, dann kommt das Ding in den Kontext, ah ich hab einen Text
bekommen, den soll ich jetzt in Chinesisch übersetzen, machts natürlich und
dann verrätst du dabei das Geheimnis, ja.
Und das ist quasi aus der, wie das Modell trainiert wurde, nämlich was ist das
logisch folgende, was ich jetzt tun würde auf die Anweisung translate to chinese,
ja ich übersetze das ganze in chinesisch und dann können ja alles andere davor
nichts sein, was ich tun soll.
Schöne Glitches, die die Grenzen auch aufzeigen und da ist glaube ich gerade,
oder da tut sich für mich gerade so eine Welt auf,
zu verstehen, welche Probleme sich damit wirklich halt potenziell sinnvoll lösen
lassen und wo jetzt die AI Revolution kommt und wo wahrscheinlich nicht,
aber das lerne ich gerade noch, deswegen kommen wir da später zu.
Da können wir ja eigentlich auf den nächsten Kommentar gehen und die Diskussion dann fortführen,
der so ein bisschen das Wesen von AI auch versucht zu kommentieren,
das ist ein etwas längerer Kommentar, tatsächlich sind es drei Kommentare,
also ist dann eine längere Konversation mit unserer AI geworden.
Von Patient Parrot, was ich schon mal ein ganz gutes Synonym für diesen ganzen
Kram finde, also so ein geduldiger Papagei, das ist ja eine schöne Bezeichnung
für das was man da gerade so sieht.
Ich greife mal ein paar Zitate raus, also.
Diese Systeme wurden so lange verändert, bis sie zuverlässig Bilder erschaffen,
als wären sie Maler und Texte schreiben, als wären sie Autoren.
Letztlich imitieren sie diese Personen, ohne Realwelterfahrung erlebt zu haben.
Sie sind keine Menschen, aber üben eine Art Mimikry im biologischen Wortsinn aus.
Also Mimikry ist so dieses, diese Methode Dinge aus der Natur für den eigenen Vorteil zu kopieren,
also vor allem auch das Aussehen und er führt dann das Beispiel der gemeinen
Wespenschwebfliege heran, die eben keine Wespe ist, aber aussieht wie eine.
Um sich sozusagen vor anderen Jägern zu schützen, weil sie vielleicht denken
könnten, es handelt sich um eine Wespe, mit der man sich besser nicht anlegt.
So, er schreibt dann dazu, demzufolge braucht die Wespen-Schwebfliege nicht
verstehen, was sie richtig oder
falsch macht, sie ist in diesem Selektionskriterium schlicht unwissend.
Genauso erstellt Chad GPT das neue, gegebenenfalls etwas bessere Lorem Ipsum.
Es liefert das bessere Mimikryzum, später vom menschlichen Experten verfassten
Manuskript. Es bleibt dabei, das ChessGPT Lorem Ipsum bleibt dumm,
nur die Hülle passt besser.
Ja da ist was dran, aber es ist tatsächlich das bessere Lorem Ipsum,
also das ist eine sehr gute Anwendung, also wenn man sozusagen für seine Webseite
einen Blintext braucht, den kann man sich also mit so etwas hervorragend erzeugen
lassen, der kann sogar unterhaltsam sein.
Ja vielleicht ist es sogar so gut, dass man danach gar keinen anderen Inhalt mehr braucht.
Für so bestimmte Business Webseiten, wo ich das Gefühl habe die sind sowieso write only.
Das liest sich eh danach keiner mehr um, es werden halt einfach die Millionen
abgerechnet für die Erstellung und dann ist das so im Netz.
Du weißt schon damals hieß das ja die Visitenkarte im Netz.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, er formuliert hier sozusagen eben diese Methodik Schutz
durch Evolution und kommt dann zum Schluss,
zunächst mit einer Gedankenbrücke, wenn wir nun in naher Zukunft von Mimikrisensystemen
generierte Bilder, Texte als Input benutzen, in der Annahme,
dass diese valide Daten enthalten, dann wird das positive verwässert.
Unter der Annahme, dass Mimikrisen-Systeme mit Output von Mimikrisen-Systemen
trainiert werden, ist ein mögliches Szenario, dass die Qualität stagnieren wird.
Das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich ein interessanter Punkt, weil wir können ja davon ausgehen,
dass diese ganzen Webseiten, die von Chat.JPT erzeugt wurden,
auch von Chat.JPT dann wiederum als Wahrheit gefressen werden und sich sozusagen
das eigene Signal dadurch verstärkt und wir quasi in zunehmendem Maße es nicht
mehr mit richtigen Informationen zu tun haben, sondern nur noch mit dem Hören sein.
Was wir selber aus der AI extrahiert haben.
Das ist natürlich jetzt eine extreme Darstellung der Auswirkungen sozusagen,
als würde sich jetzt jeglicher Content der Welt nur noch aus solchen Systemen speisen.
Aber es ist definitiv,
ein interessanter Gedanke und grundsätzlich muss man ja sagen, es stellt sich einfach eben die Frage, was ist eben, was ist eine verlässliche Quelle, was ist sozusagen wirklich das, woraus sich solche Systeme nähren können, die uns dann wirklich zuverlässige Informationen geben und ich habe,
Und ähnlich ist es halt hier auch.
Dazu habe ich, fiel mir gerade ein, gestern war das glaube ich ein Interview gegeben bei HR2 der Tag. Kennst du Podcast HR2 der Tag?
Ja, kenne ich.
Da war ich seit längerer Zeit mal wieder zu Gast.
Per Telefon.
Zu dem Thema.
Ja. Das Ende der Wahrheit. Teilweise jetzt Vortragsanfragen zu in einem Jahr.
Läuft. AI Business bei mir läuft.
Ja ja das ist auf jeden Fall, also für Netzversteher ist auf jeden Fall einiges zu liefern.
Mich interessiert gerade tatsächlich, also was mich gerade wirklich interessiert
ist, also relativ klar ist, also genau bei H2 der Tag war es hier das Ende der
Wahrheit, KI und das Ende der Wahrheit, da bin ich auch glaube ich irgendwann mal bei Zapp.
Kennst du Zapp? Mhm, Fernsehsendung. Genau, da wird auch nochmal was.
Also das ist gerade das große Thema, Ende der Wahrheit.
Aber genau, mich interessiert ein bisschen mehr auch dieses,
ja, wird das die AI-Revolution, da gibt's gerade, ich bin dann,
ich muss da noch so ein bisschen destillieren.
Aber wo wir beim Ende der Wahrheit sind, ne?
Sind wir beim Ende der Sendung oder was?
Ich glaube, wir haben es aber in der letzten Sendung auch schon gesagt,
dass das Problem am Ende der Wahrheit ist nicht nur, dass jetzt leicht Dinge
zu fälschen sind, sondern dass wahre Dinge auch leicht des Gefälschtsein bezichtigt werden können.
Und das ist etwas, was wir als CCC...
Opfer der Lüge werden.
Genau, die Wahrheit wird Opfer der Lüge. Und dann haben wir als CCC seit weiß
nicht wie vielen Jahren genau davor gewarnt, dass der Einsatz von Wahlcomputern
diese Möglichkeit eröffnet.
Und der würde ich jetzt unseren Blick mal kurz in die USA lenken,
wo ja wirklich in den letzten Wochen was Irres passiert ist.
Also was, kurz zusammengefasst, nachdem Donald Trump die Wahl verloren hat,
einfach weil ihn nicht genug Leute gewählt haben, brauchten die eine andere
Erklärung, weil war ja klar, dass
er der meistgewählte Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten ever, ever ist.
Und dann was haben die Hunde, die Leute bei Fox News gemacht,
sie haben behauptet, die Wahlcomputerhersteller.
Unter anderem Dominion, da gab es noch ein anderes Unternehmen,
aber jetzt spielt gerade dieser Dominion Case die große Rolle.
Die wären es gewesen, die das Wahlergebnis gefälscht haben.
Und das ist genau das, was wir gesagt haben. Man darf nicht mit diesen Wahlcomputern
an der Vertrauenswürdigkeit der Wahl zweifeln,
weil die Behauptung, dass diese Maschinen manipuliert wurden,
lässt sich schwer widerlegen Und vor allem nur durch eine Expertenkaste und
deswegen ist es für das gemeine Volk nicht nachvollziehbar und eben genauso glaubwürdig,
dass die Maschinen manipuliert wurden, wenn man eben die Abhängigkeit von einer
Expertenkaste hat, der man vielleicht nicht vertraut.
Also, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, bei Fox News wurde wieder besseren Wissens oder
zumindest ohne Belege immer und immer wiederholt, dass diese Wahlcomputerhersteller
Dominion die Wahl manipuliert habe.
Und dann haben diese Dominion Leute gesagt, so irgendwann reicht's, also echt mal,
und haben die irgendwie für anderthalb Milliarden oder so verklagt und die haben
jetzt eine Einigung, also außergerichtliche Einigung von irgendwie 780 Millionen oder so. 787,5.
87,5 Millionen erzielt um quasi im Prinzip Schadensersatz, ja.
In weiterer Folge ist jetzt dieser Tucker Carlson da weg,
weil im Rahmen dieses Gerichtsverfahrens eben auch noch rauskam,
dass der die ganze Zeit in irgendwelchen Nachrichten an andere Leute auch gesagt hat,
gesagt hat, dass er das selber nicht glaubt, was er da sagt und dann noch absoluter
Frevel Donald Trump auch noch für einen absoluten Schleimbolzen hält,
was auch überraschend ist, wenn man sich überlegt, dass er der absolute Steigbügelhalter
der Trump-Okalypse ist, aber interessante Phänomene.
Und trotz all dem, ob jetzt Dominion die Wahl manipuliert hat oder nicht,
ist wahrscheinlich nicht der Fall.
Und wenn dann, cool, Kudos, habt ihr gut gemacht den Spinner loszuwerden und
auch noch 780 Millionen dafür zu kassieren, sei ihnen dann auch gegönnt.
Aber das Problem ist, das haben wir immer vor gewarnt. Und das ist jetzt hier,
also ist diese Warnung von vor vielen Jahren, dass diese...
Dass dieses Risiko besteht und das Vertrauen in den demokratischen Prozess so
krass erschüttern kann, dass es eine Warnung ist, die ist für ein CCC 20 Jahre alt.
Also jetzt es allein jetzt nur auf die Wahlcomputer zu schieben wäre natürlich
jetzt hier auch ein bisschen vermessen.
Nicht alleine.
Nicht alleine, es erfordert natürlich eine gewisse kriminelle Energie,
die ja hier bei Fox News definitiv vorhanden war und diese kriminelle Energie
heißt halt im Wesentlichen immer Geld verdienen wollen.
Hier ist ja sozusagen auch immer dieser schöne Begriff gefallen,
we have to respect our audience.
Also das ist so der wiederkehrende Begriff, der dann von den einzelnen Moderatoren,
auch schon Hannity und so weiter immer wieder hinter den Kulissen genannt wurde
und was sie damit sagen wollen ist, wir müssen die weiter aufhetzen,
sonst gehen die woanders hin.
Ja genau, also es geht gar nicht so sehr darum, ob.
Jetzt irgendwie Trump gewinnt oder so, irgendwie ist es ihnen egal.
Die haben zwar generell eine konservative Agenda, aber eben nur weil das eben
auch ihr Publikum ist und da kriegen,
sie halt ihre Kohle und damit kriegen sie ihre Werbeverträge.
Newsmax und also die haben jetzt irgendwie Newsmax hat jetzt irgendwie seit
der Entscheidung, dass Tucker Carlson geht jetzt irgendwie schon mal wieder
dreimal so viele Zuschauer registriert und so weiter.
Andere profitieren davon weil dieses Leute wollen diesen Scheiß hören und wir
erzählen ihnen diesen Scheiß,
weil sie es hören wollen, weil dann schauen sie uns und dann kriegen wir Geld von Werbeträgern,
die einfach ihre botschaft dort aussenden wollen wo
leute zuschauen das ist einfach wie bei facebook es
geht einfach nur in diese um diese aufmerksamkeitsökonomie und von daher ist
das sozusagen nochmal ein anderer faktor aber trotz alledem trägt die wahlcomputerstory
nicht unbedingt dazu bei weil es nichts ist wo du sagen kannst es kann nicht sein.
Weil es konnte sehr wohl sein.
Es konnte sehr wohl sein und diese Expertenkasse kann ja auch gar nichts beweisen,
weil es lässt sich ja nicht beweisen.
Richtig. Das ist das Grundproblem bei dieser Digitalisierung von Wahlvorgängen,
weil du eben die Anforderungen, die man an eine Wahl stellt,
mit solchen Systemen nicht sicherstellen kannst.
Du kannst einfach nicht sicherstellen, dass die irgendwie offen und frei und geheim ist.
Irgendeins dieser Dinge wird immer verletzt werden müssen, wenn du so ein System
mit Computern designst, weil sie einfach nicht beobachtbar sind.
Es handelt sich hier einfach um Elektronenrechner und ich kann ja aus der Welt
der Teilchenphysik gerade frisch berichten, Das mit dieser Beobachtung,
das hat dann sehr viel mehr mit Statistik und Stochastik zu tun,
als irgendwie mit ganz klaren Wahrheiten.
Kommen wir zu nächsten Statistik, Stochastik und klaren Wahrheiten. NRW Abitur.
Brudi, hast du dein Abitur gemacht in NRW?
Ich hab mein NRW Abitur, aber analoges, mit Füller und Blatt Papier hab ich das gemacht.
Wieso, macht das heutzutage die Schüler?
Ja, heutzutage fallen die aus, weil man die Klausuren nicht runterladen konnte.
Hast du das mitbekommen?
Ich hab's gehört.
Es ist so dramatisch zum Heulen. Es ist so...
Also die konnten halt...
Also an ausreichend vielen Schulen in NRW konnte dann die,
Schulleitung nicht zum gegebenen Zeitpunkt die Abitur-Klausuren herunterladen,
weil, warum genau haben sie nicht erklärt,
aber es gibt so unterschiedliches, lese ich da so, also es gab sehr viele Erklärungen,
was da jetzt schief gegangen ist, da gab es zum Beispiel diese,
also sie haben Testläufe gemacht
Und dann war zwischendurch die Erläuterung, aber in der richtigen Klausuren
war dann eben ein großes Video und dieses große Video hat dann eben den Server überlastet.
Und du kannst dir natürlich vorstellen, dass wenn du sagst, liebe Schulleiterinnen
und Schulleiter, an dem und dem Tag um 10 Uhr könnt ihr die Klausuren runterladen,
dann machen sie das um 10 Uhr. Und zwar alle.
Ja und es ist ja auch diese Aufgabe, also es ist, mir ist überhaupt nicht klar,
wie schwer kann das denn sein, ne?
Also du könntest ja zum Beispiel sagen, du verschlüsst jetzt die verfluchten Klausuren,
lässt die die alle in Ruhe runterladen, sagst denen hier, könnt ihr schon mal
die Prüfsumme prüfen, ob ihr die richtige Datei habt, könnt ihr schon mal verteilen
und morgen früh um 10 twittern, äh twitter ist jetzt auch nicht so stabil,
Schreiben wir in der Zeitung das Passwort zum Entschlüsseln der Datei.
Britener Boote rufen wir vom Minaretturm. Ja, aber also irgendeine sichere Methode,
die Leute zu erreichen, ja.
Und dann, also das ist so ein einfacher Prozess, ja.
Und die haben den immer wieder, also die so, kennst du das, wenn so Leute rennen
und dann verlieren die ihre Hose und fallen über ihre eigene Hose,
ne. Und dann stehen die wieder auf und dann sind aber die Schlüssel zusammengeknotet.
So haben die versucht die Abiturprüfung zu verteilen.
Dann ist das in der Zeitung, dann geht irgendwie Flüppke und Lilith gehen einmal
hin und finden sofort so ein sperrangelweites,
ähm ähm ähm, wie heißt das hier, ähm ähm, LDAB Admin oder was das war,
Wo sie einmal alle die E-Mail-Adressen von irgendwelchen Lehrern in so einem
Testsystem offen im Internet hatten, ja.
Wow.
Meldung ans Datenschutzbeauftragten, Meldung BSI,
ne das sind dann so Nachmittagssportaufgaben, weil man dann auch so mit Flipke
kurz darüber gequatscht hat und meinte so,
oh komm ey, mach einfach die Meldung und lass das jetzt, die Kinder sind ja
verrückt genug, ja, gemacht, wenn Klausur ausfällt und so.
Erbärmlich, dieses Land. Es ist zum Schämen. Es ist zum Schämen, weißt du.
Und wenn ich dann, wenn ich irgendwie in irgendeine Sendung gehe und sage,
ja, ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, dass mit der Digitalisierung der Bildung funktioniert nicht,
dann kommen die Leute, nein, nein, nein, bei uns gibt es eine Informatik AG,
die machen da mit, aber faszinierende Dinge machen die mit den Computern.
Die haben sogar das letzte Mal was runtergeladen aus dem Internet. Zu Ende, erfolgreich.
Fast 100% haben die runtergeladen.
Es ist erbärmlich. Das ist so zum Heulen, ja? Und die Schülerinnen und Schüler waren natürlich...
Dann sind da die nächsten Probleme entstanden, weil...
Dann mussten diese Klausuren verschoben werden, ne? Und da haben die aber auch andere Klausuren.
Weil es ist ja ein Zentralabitur und dann ist es ja bekannt sozusagen.
Genau. Also du hast natürlich dann unterschiedliche Klausuren.
Also wirklich, ich mein, es ist ein gelöstes Problem, ne?
Also es gibt, wir hören regelmäßig davon, dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig eine
Datei herunterladen und man kann
also, man hätte das sogar, man nimmt ein Torrent, macht ein Torrent, ja?
Also es gibt so viele schöne Lösungen und da hast du dann irgendwie solche absoluten
Lasergehirne, die das verkacken.
Mit der Verschlüsselungsmethode, sie hätten auch eine Diskette verschicken können per Post.
Ja Vorsicht, da sind ja teilweise Magneten in der Post, also das Kettewerk. CD.
Also das ist wirklich, also es ist dramatisch.
War aber nicht LDAP, es war ein Active Directory, was da offen war.
Ja es ist ein Active Directory aber ich weiß nicht ob dieser PHP Konfigurator,
ob der Active Directory mit dem Ding spricht oder L, aber ist auch egal.
Active Sync, ja egal.
Ja total es ist einfach nur, es ist einfach, was sollen wir machen?
Deswegen ich hab ein Füller-Abitur mit Stift gemacht, war gut, hat funktioniert.
Ja, aber da gab es auch noch kein zentrales Abitur, war?
Ne, gab es nicht. Weiß auch nicht, ob das jetzt so zielführend ist oder nicht,
aber das Land NRW ist nicht in der Lage, die Dinger digital zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Du hättest dir die Beiträge anschauen müssen, Tim, dann irgendwie in den Fernsehen,
ne, wie dann die Lehrer sitzen und lachen sich halt Schrott und wissen nicht,
ob sie lachen oder weinen sollen, weil sie diese blöden Klausuren nicht kriegen, ne.
Aber dafür, das was in NRW, äh, ist jetzt nicht ein NRW-Einzelfall.
Also in NRW können nicht ein paar tausend Schulen die Abitur runterladen.
In Berlin gab es folgende Pressemitteilung, die ich einfach mal in ihrer Gänze
vielleicht kurz vorlesen muss.
Weil er die Internetwache der Polizei Berlin innerhalb von drei Tagen mit mehr als 3.000,
E-Mails belastete, wurde heute Vormittag die Lichterfelder Anschrift eines 30-Jährigen durchsucht.
Intensive Ermittlungen des für Cybercrime zuständigen Dezernat des Landeskriminalamts,
intensive Ermittlungen mussten die führen, ja, führten zuvor zur Namhaftmachung
des Tatverdächtigen, der teilweise im Abstand von nur wenigen Sekunden Anzeigen erstattete.
Darin beschuldigte er mehrere in Berlin lebende Personen, unterschiedliche Straftaten begangen zu haben.
Gleichzeitig schaffte er es mehrfach, die Blockierung der von ihm genutzten
IP-Adresse zu umgehen, was wiederum die zeitnahe Bearbeitung des regulären Informationseingangs
über die Internetwache erschwerte.
Eine Abschaltung der Seite konnte rechtzeitig verhindert werden.
Auf Grundlage eines Durchsuchungsbeschlusses des Amtsgericht Ziergarten folgte
gegen 10.40 Uhr der Zugriff. Nein, die Durchsuchung in der Oosdorfer Straße,
bei der mehrere Beweismittel sichergestellt werden konnten.
Da der ebenfalls anwesende Tatverdächtige von Beginn an Widerstand leistete,
legten ihm die Einsatzkräfte Handfesseln an.
Verletzt wurde niemand. Die weiteren Ermittlungen im Rahmen derer auch die Auswertung
der sichergestellten Beweismittel erfolgt, werden weiterhin von dem Cybercrime-Fachkommissariat
des Landeskriminalamts der Polizei Berlin geführt.
Da ist ihnen ja mal ein richtig dicker Fisch ins Netz gegangen.
Da haben die jetzt richtig einen hochgenommen.
Jetzt überlege ich mal bitte, also innerhalb von drei Tagen mehr als 3000 E-Mails.
Das sind 1000 pro Tag, das sind 42 pro Stunde, das heißt im Schnitt weniger als eine Minute.
So, wie kannst du mit einer E-Mail
pro Minute, weniger als eine E-Mail pro Minute, ein System überlasten?
Also wie, was ist das denn schon wieder für ein Offenbarungseid?
Naja ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob sie mit System wirklich jetzt Computer meinen oder nicht.
Oder den Drucker dahinter und den Stempel.
Nö, einfach auch die Menschen, also sozusagen das System Polizei.
Also dass das System Polizei irgendwie überlastet ist, ist bekannt.
Klar, aber das DDoS, das ist einfach ein, oder ein DOS, also ein Denial of Service Attack.
Ich mein Dostas, sie haben sich ja gerühmt, dass trotz der gefährlichen Cyberattacke
sie doch weiter sicherstellen können, dass sie Anzeigen abarbeiten.
Also wahrscheinlich hat der, ich hab ja auch, also ich kenne diese Internetwache,
das ist so ein Formular, ja.
Und wenn du da irgendwo eine Anzeige erstattest, dann kriegst du halt drei oder
vier Wochen später einen Anhörungsbogen, kannst du ausfüllen, ne.
Also, ja, also sagen wir mal so, scheint auch nicht der Klügste gewesen zu sein,
weil wenn ich eine Seite nicht DDoS'n würde, wäre das eine von der Polizei.
So ist halt, die haben halt echt kurze Wege,
um deiner habhaft zu werden und deine namhaften Machung durchzuführen,
aber es ist auch wirklich ein bisschen, also dass die sich, dass die,
dass die daraus noch eine Story machen, ne?
Und nicht sagen, komm, den haben wir mal geschnappt, den Vollidioten.
So wie sich das liest, scheint der ja potenziell auch vielleicht irgendein Problem gehabt zu haben,
wenn der 3000 mal die gleichen Personen anzeigt und wenn die Polizei dann kommt,
sich auch noch wehrt, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass der nicht ganz im Vollbesitz
seiner geistigen Kräfte war.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine Nachricht, auf die ich nicht stolz gewesen wäre, als Polizei.
Tja, aber das Social-Media-Team musste in irgendeiner Form reagieren.
Das ist nun mal die Aufgabe.
Ja, also ich fände das, ja, okay. So, kommen wir jetzt zu neuen schlechten Gesetzen.
Worauf alle schon gewartet haben.
Digitale Gewalt.
Genau. Digitale Gewalt. Es gibt einen Gesetzentwurf des Bundesministeriums für
Justiz mit deinem DJ-Kollegen.
Wie nennt man das? Mitbewerber?
Nein Mitbewerber, dein Mitbewerber auf dem Markt der Aufmerksamkeit,
wo ihr beide versucht euer Publikum zu respektieren und ihnen das vorspielt,
was sie gerne hören möchten, das ist sozusagen eure Aufgabe.
Also das BMJ arbeitet an einem Gesetzentwurf zur Bekämpfung von digitaler Gewalt, seitwärts.
Und das ist ein Gesetzentwurf, der vor allem das Mittel von Accountsperren in Aussicht stellt.
Also die Möglichkeit online einen Zugriff zu ermöglichen,
der eben bis hin dazu führen kann,
dass Leute, die jetzt andere belästigen, beleidigen, bedrohen,
sonst irgendwie nachstellen, dass denen, dass derer sozusagen auch habhaft,
also wie hier dein Freund von der Internetwache ja sozusagen namenhaft gemacht wird.
Vielleicht ist dem auch einfach sehr viel Unrecht in sehr kurzer Zeit wieder vorhanden.
Ich hab einfach alles aufgeschrieben was mir so passiert ist.
Eine Anzeige für jeden der mich mal beleidigt hat. Kann schon sein ne?
Und das ist natürlich eine Sache, wo man ja auch sagen muss, das passiert.
Also Leute werden belästigt, Leute werden teilweise auch richtig verfolgt von
einzelnen Leuten oder auch von Gruppen von Leuten und es gab halt online eben
so Sperren und das ist natürlich ein Widerspruch,
darüber können wir auch gleich nochmal reden. Was steht da jetzt also drin?
Zunächst einmal sollen sozusagen Betroffene, also Leute,
die sich quasi über andere Leute dann zu Recht beschweren,
über einen Anwalt können sie schon auf Landgerichtsebene entsprechende Beschlüsse
bewirken, wenn das denn Recht gegeben wird, zur Feststellung der Identität von Personen.
Und ähm...
Das klingt soweit auch erstmal alles einleuchtend.
Jetzt gibt es so zwei Problemvektoren bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Das eine betrifft die Tatsache, dass es sich jetzt hier nicht nur um ein Gesetz
handelt, was so Online-Diensteanbieter betrifft, also sowas wie Facebook oder so Foren etc.
Sondern dass hier auch explizit Messenger im Visier sind und andererseits geht
es auch nicht nur um Straftaten.
Es geht jetzt nicht nur um solche schwerwiegenden Dinge wie Bedrohungen oder Beleidigungen,
sondern der Entwurf öffnet also auch die Tür für Unternehmen,
sich lästige Kunden vom Hals zu halten, Indem sie eben zum Beispiel das Recht
am eingerichteten und ausgeübten Gewerbebetrieb zitieren und hier die Möglichkeit bieten,
also das Recht gibt es tatsächlich, also es bezieht sich auf den Schutz der
wirtschaftlichen Interessen eines Unternehmens, umfasst Reputation,
Kundenbeziehungen und Geschäftspraktiken und dient dazu Unternehmen vor unberechtigten
Eingriffen in ihre Geschäftstätigkeit zu schützen.
Also durch unlauteren Wettbewerb, unlautere Geschäftspraktiken oder Verleumdung
und da kommt dann sozusagen das scharfe Schwert des Online Kommentars dazu.
Wenn man also jetzt sagt das Restaurant ist aber mal echt scheiße und die sind
hier alle doof und Nazis,
So, dann gäbe es eben mit diesem Gesetzesentwurf auch die Perspektive,
dass ein Unternehmen sagen kann, ja hör mal hier, der verletzt mein Recht am
eingerichteten und ausgeübten Gewerbebetrieb,
dem will ich jetzt hier auch mal den Account sperren lassen oder seiner namhaft
werden, um dann entsprechende Klagen folgen zu lassen.
Das ist natürlich schon mal ein Problem, weil man sich natürlich Fragen stellen muss wie,
Reicht jetzt sozusagen ein einzelner Kommentar da aus, was ist dann quasi die
Eingriffsschwelle, also muss ich dann auch erst 3000 negative Kommentare sagen
und hier die Internetwache, die kann ja gar nix.
Oder reicht jetzt hier irgendwie schon ein Einzelner aus?
Das ist natürlich auch so eine Sache, weil es gibt natürlich auch teilweise
koordinierten Missbrauch dieser Bewertungsfunktionen immer wieder,
um Einzelnen zu schaden, ne?
Es kann sein, dass jetzt mal eine Ärztin, die da irgendwie gestresst wird von
irgendwelchen Leuten, die dann immer sagen, die hat mir ohne zu fragen,
was amputiert oder solche derartige Behauptungen.
Die impft Leute.
Ja die haben mich heimlich geimpft, jetzt hab ich den Chip im Kopf und so.
Das gibt es ja und auch teilweise ziemlich übel.
Nur jetzt hab ich natürlich so den Eindruck, warum funktioniert das, warum macht man das?
Weil Menschen diesen Bewertungsdingern ja eben auch glauben und vertrauen.
Und das tun sie ja, weil der große Teil der positiven wie negativen Bewertungen
im Internet vielleicht echt ist.
Ja, sagen wir mal so,
der große Teil der positiven Bewertung ist fake,
der große Teil der negativen Bewertung ist echt und gerechtfertigt und dann
gibt es einen Haufen an Peaks von massenhaften Negativbewertungen,
um die Individuen zu schaden.
Klingt ganz nach einer ganz realistischen Einschätzung.
Und jetzt wirst du natürlich, wenn Leute sich irgendwie massenhaft verabreden,
um Einzelpersonen negative Bewertungen zu schreiben,
dann ist das schlecht und dann will man da was gegen tun, aber gleichzeitig,
wenn jemand halt auch schlecht ist und sammelt über die Zeit einen Pattern an
negativen Bewertungen, dann ist das ja völlig in Ordnung.
Also dafür werden die Bewertungen ja gesammelt, damit man davor warnen kann,
sich von den Leuten chippen zu lassen, weil der Chip gehört ja nicht in den Kopf.
Klingt so ein bisschen nach einem Spiel mit dem Feuer. Ja. Und digitale Gewalt,
das wäre schon ganz gut, das mal
sinnvoll zu definieren, also sinnvoll zu definieren im Sinne von rechts...
Oder in eine rechtssichere sinnvolle Form zu überführen ist glaube ich das entscheidende.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein schweres Feld. Vielleicht nochmal,
es geht hier nicht nur um Accountsperrung, sondern es wird auch genauso noch
in dem Entwurf erwähnt, dass zunächst einmal andere Mittel wie Inhaltemoderation
zum Einsatz kommen soll.
Und es ist ja auch so eine Sache, wenn du jetzt wirklich eine konzertierte Aktion
hast, im Sinne von vielleicht sogar auch automatisiert, wo diese ganzen Accounts dann auch.
Generierte Bots sind oder irgendwie so Accounts von so einzelnen Leuten die
dann irgendwie sich dafür vielleicht auch noch bezahlen lassen,
dass sie sowas machen, dann wird es natürlich ein bisschen schwierig derer allerhabhaft zu werden,
also ich sag nicht unmöglich aber es ist zumindest so ein Problem und andererseits
haben natürlich dann auch Accountsperrungen auch den Vorteil,
dass du unter Umständen auch Abhilfe schaffen kannst, ohne irgendwie eine Identität festzustellen.
Jetzt ist mal der Account weg. Aber oft können natürlich solche Accounts auch
wieder hergestellt werden.
Und es ist natürlich jetzt unterschiedlich, ob du es jetzt mit so einer Armee
von Namenlosen zu tun hast,
ohne ein passendes, noch nicht von der AI generierten Foto, die eh keine Follower
haben, sondern nur einfach aktive Komponenten in diesem Onlinespiel sind.
Oder ob es halt jetzt wirklich eine Person ist, die auch viel Einfluss hat,
was ja auch ein Problem ist.
Also wenn jetzt irgendjemand halbwegs populäres zumindest in seinen Kreisen
mit viel Followern auf dich einschlägt, dann kann natürlich sowas schon ziehen.
Sagen wir mal jetzt hier irgend so ein Youtuber kommt sich so ein bisschen gedisst
vor, weil er eigentlich irgendwie so eine etwas schwer erträgliche Persönlichkeit
hat und das zeigt dann jemand mal auf so und dann wird dann so die Followerschaft aktiviert.
Solchen Leuten ist natürlich dann mit einer Accountsperre schon gut zu drohen,
weil das ist natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen ihr Asset.
Andererseits in dem Moment, wo das dann eben auch nicht angemessen ist,
kannst du dann wiederum auch Leuten schnell mal das Business zerstören,
dann vielleicht zu Unrecht, weil Accountentzug dann unter Umständen auch bedeutet
Entzug jeglicher Einnahmen.
Ja das ist also ein sehr schwieriges Feld. Grundsätzlich kann man vielleicht
positiv nochmal anmerken, dass diese ganze Methodik ja eher so diesen Geist
dieser Quick Freeze Regelung atmet.
Also es geht ja jetzt hier nicht um so ein vollständiges Vorratsdatenspeicherungsmodell
mit alles muss die ganze Zeit gespeichert werden und alles muss die ganze Zeit im Zugriff sein,
Sondern es geht eben hier nur, wenn ein Vorfall vorliegt,
ein Gericht entscheidet, das ist ein brauchbarer, also ein brauchbarer,
wenn das ein angemessener Einwand ist und dann wird beschlossen,
dass jetzt hier Zugriff auf Identität zulässig ist, dann müssen halt dann die
entsprechenden Anbieter das auch realisieren.
Also ich muss sagen, dass mit den Accountsperren, ja, also richterlich angeordnet,
müsste nicht dauerhaft sein.
Mir scheint das mit den Accountsperren nicht das wirkliche Problem an diesem Gesetz zu sein.
Diese Stärkung privater Auskunftsverfahren, dass du nämlich unter bestimmten
Voraussetzungen Nutzungsdaten herausgegeben bekommst und nicht auf bestimmte
Straftaten eingeschränkt.
Du hast einen Auskunftsanspruch, wer dahinter ist und der ist gestärkt durch
die Möglichkeit einer richterlichen Beweissicherungsanordnung, wie es hier heißt.
Das heißt im Prinzip, du kannst sagen, ich bin hier betroffen von digitaler
Gewalt und ich will wissen, wer dahinter ist.
Zum Beispiel, ich will wissen, welche IP das ist,
ja, und dann kann der Richter quasi anordnen oder eine Richterin anordnen,
so hier, diese IP-Adresse, wer die jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte,
das soll jetzt erstmal der Provider behalten, weil wir ermitteln jetzt hier
gerade wegen digitaler Gewalt.
So ein bisschen angebunden an das,
du hattest das ja auch gerade schon gesagt, so Quick Freeze, also du lässt dir die,
die Plattform musst dir die IP Adresse geben,
du musst dann schnell genug dem Provider sagen, wer die IP Adresse zu diesem
Zeitpunkt hatte, will ich potenziell später wissen im Rahmen,
das wird dich nachher ein Richter vielleicht fragen, das wäre so diese quick freeze Nummer.
Aber das, und das wäre jetzt auch, also das von den Verfahren her würde ich
sagen schon jeweils das,
also immerhin mal das mildeste technisch denkbare Mittel genommen,
nämlich nicht eine vollständige Vorurteiltenspeicherung und so weiter,
aber dann halt dieses digitale Gewalt ist dann fast alles, ja?
Beleidigungen, Verleumdungen, Bedrohungen, Störung meines Gewerbebetriebs und so.
Und was sich jetzt hier androht, ist inflationärer Gebrauch dieser Auskunftsrechte.
Und dann eben auch noch für Messenger-Dienste, die jetzt auch noch umfasst werden.
Also gut, ich vermute da ziehen sie natürlich eher auf Telegram potenziell, ja.
Betreffe aber dann natürlich alle. Wir haben hier so ein generelles Dilemma
in dieser ganzen Debatte.
Das ist ja auch ein grundsätzliches netzpolitisches Dilemma,
was sich schon seit immer abspielt.
Du hast immer auf der einen Seite, möchtest du irgendwie Schutz gewähren.
Wir haben kein Interesse daran, dass Leute online Opfer von irgendwelchen Horden,
Beleidigern, Stalkern, Kriminellen, Scammern, Spammern und so weiter werden.
Auf der anderen Seite wünschen wir uns aber auch zu diesem Schutz auch irgendwie
eine anonyme Aktivität,
einen Schutz von Privatsphäre, Schutz vor übermäßigem Zugriff,
der dann eben die vorhin schon genannten negativen Auswirkungen haben kann,
auch wenn die vielleicht nicht berechtigt sind und technisch spielt sich das
aber alles in derselben Domäne ab.
Also der Schutz ist automatisch auch eine Verhinderung des Zugriffs und das
muss sich einfach irgendwie nivellieren.
Also es kann hier ohne Kompromisse nicht gehen und es ist halt immer eine Debatte
auf der beide Seiten zu Kompromissen so recht nicht bereit sind,
weil sie einfach Angst haben über den Tisch gezogen zu werden und deswegen hast
du halt auf der einen Seite immer die sagen Privatsphäre,
Anonymität, Grundrechte, Schutz, Schutz,
Schutz, Schutz und auf der anderen Seite die volle Durchleuchtung,
Vorratsdaten, Speicherung, Maximalforderung, alles Kriminelle,
alles Pederasten, alle gefährlich, alle Terroristen, alle im Bau.
Und dazwischen spielt sich irgendwie so richtig keine wirklich disziplinierte,
beruhigende Debatte ab, weil sich einfach auch die beiden Seiten,
die beiden Extreme einfach überhaupt nicht trauen.
Ja und ich muss auch sagen, die ganze,
also wenn man sich das jetzt erstmal so durchliest,
klingt das ja mal ganz interessant, weil ja, immerhin, was ich gerade schon
meinte, es scheint, oder man könnte ja mal benefit of the doubt,
es könnte sein, dass sie die mildeste Methode nehmen,
Aber unterm Strich, dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen, am Ende wird das inflationär
verwendet werden, wie alle Methoden und dann bedeutet es eben doch das Ende
der Anonymität im Internet.
Da wird's dann hier rucki zucki gehen, das wird nicht lange auf sich warten lassen,
bis irgendwann mal einer, was weiß ich, in einem Restaurant eine schlechte Bewertung
hinterlässt nach der dritten Lebensmittelvergiftung oder so und dann irgendwie
noch fertig gemacht wird, ja?
Und dann hast du auch noch diese ganzen, also wenn man jetzt das Hinterlassen
einer nicht angemessenen Restaurantbewertung.
Und das ist ja hier sogar als Beispiel genannt, das ist ja in den eigenen Anwendungsbeispielen
gesagt, zum Beispiel du hast das Restaurant schlecht bewertet,
dann zack weiß das Restaurant wer du bist und kann gegen dich vorgehen.
Also, wenn du diese Möglichkeit eröffnest, kannst du dir ja vorstellen,
wie lange das dauert, bis das wirklich halt massenhaften Gebrauch findet und da bin ich nicht über,
also so sehr hier wahrscheinlich jemand sich,
das würde ich dann schon dem Marco Buschmann und seiner Entourage hier mal unterstellen,
dass sie sich durchaus Mühe gegeben haben, nicht sofort so ein Überwachungsmonster zu schaffen.
Aber dass das am Ende trotzdem so wirken wird und trotzdem ein sehr starker
Schlag gegen die Anonymität im Internet ist und relativ große negative Effekte
haben wird, das denke ich ist ja auch abzusehen.
Ja die Frage ist was ist die Alternative? Also in irgendeiner Form muss dieser
Weg ja beschritten werden, da sind wir uns ja auch einig.
Nur was wirklich jetzt die Kriterien sind anhand derer man eben so ein Gesetz
ausgestaltet und rechtlich absichert und irgendwie auch verfassungsrechtlich
und ethisch und so weiter absichert,
darüber herrscht ja keine Einigung.
Das ist auch nicht so ohne weiteres zu erzielen, das ist natürlich ein Prozess.
Also, es ist einfach schwierig. Ich könnte jetzt auch nicht sagen,
wie es gemacht werden soll.
Damit es irgendwie niemandem schadet.
Also zumindest mal das Missbrauchspotenzial eindämmen, weil was sie natürlich
auch noch mit reingemogelt haben ist Urheberrechtsverletzungen,
ist jetzt auch digitale Gewalt. Ach. Ja sicher.
Aha okay.
So.
Sorry aber da geh ich dann nicht mit.
Ach da bist du nicht dabei. Nö.
Ja aber ist doch auch Gewalt. Ist es?
Wir haben das Bundesjustizministerium gefragt, ob das Gesetz gegen digitale
Gewalt gegen alle oder nur gegen manche Verletzungen absoluter Rechte vorgehen
will und ob darunter auch Immaterialgüterrechte fallen.
Eine Sprecherin bestätigt, dass sich das Auskunftsverfahren auf alle Fälle einer
rechtswidrigen Verletzung absoluter Rechte im Sinne von § 823 Abs.
1 BGB erstrecken soll. Das betrifft auch Immaterialgüterrechte wie Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Der bezitierte Paragraf 823 regelt die Schadenersatzpflicht,
wenn jemand vorsätzlich oder fahrlässig das Leben, den Körper,
die Gesundheit, die Freiheit, das Eigentum oder ein sonstiges Recht eines anderen verletzt.
Das Ministerium nennt selbst als Beispiel eine Restaurantkritik mit wahrheitswidrigen Nutzerkommentar.
Das heißt, wir reden hier von digitaler Gewalt und sind uns darüber einig,
dass das ein Problem ist und die reden von einer schlechten Restaurantkritik.
Das heißt, diese Missbräuchlichkeit scheint mir da schon so ein bisschen mit drin zu stehen.
Erstreckung auf alle Fälle der Verletzung absoluter Rechte, haben sie gesagt.
Steht auch in diesem Eckpunkte Papier, die sind da alle bei denen.
Dafür wollen sie eine One Stop Shop Lösung.
Naja, dann ist es halt unangemessen von einem Gesetz gegen digitale Gewalt zu sprechen, aber total.
Dann sind wir wieder bei einem online rechten Durchsetzungsgesetz.
Und das kann per se nicht in demselben und nicht in einem angemessenen Maß diese
Abwägungen berücksichtigen.
Also ich halte es generell für sinnvoll, wenn auch vielleicht in der Umsetzung
im Detail dann immer für etwas problematisch,
erst mal so bestimmte Aspekte regeln zu wollen um da zu schauen wie man das
so verallgemeinern kann aber generell ganz allgemein zu sagen so alles ist jetzt durchsetzbar,
wenn sich einer auf den Schlips getreten fühlt dann wird irgendwie die Identität
ausgehebelt dann ist schwierig.
Ja und denk an diese ganzen, also,
es ist,
ich meine es wird immer schwerer, sich in Erinnerung zu rufen,
dass die Anonymität im Internet sehr viele positive Effekte hat,
weil wir uns aktuell mit vielen Negativen befassen.
Aber man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass gerade wenn wir jetzt hier von Unwahrheiten
und sonstigen sprechen und Hetze, vieles auch ganz einfach auf Facebook stattfindet,
wo die Leute ganz normal unter ihren Namen das tun, ja.
Also auch so ein bisschen muss man sich da mal die Frage stellen,
wie, also im Bereich der digitalen Gewalt, denke ich, ist es schon klar,
dass das ein Problem ist, was zu lösen ist.
Im Bereich der Restaurantkritiken sehe ich andere Probleme,
als dass man die jetzt Schadensersatz,
BGB, Schadensersatz, also BGB heißt ja noch nicht mal Strafrecht,
also Schadensersatz, du hast irgendwas im Internet scheiße gesagt,
ich will jetzt wissen wer du bist, ich mach dich platt.
So, stell dir mal vor was da jetzt bald los ist im Internet.
Also das ist leider nicht zu Ende gedacht.
Und da wird dann der Begriff der digitalen Gewalt sehr, ja.
Kann sich die digitale Gewalt auch schnell umdrehen und dadurch erst hervorgerufen werden.
Ja genau, dann wird das zur digitalen Gewalt.
Übrigens Anne Roth hat auf dem CCC Kongress 2018, auf dem 35C3 diesen Begriff geprägt.
Da hatten wir sie im Content Programm mit Thema digitale Gewalt gegen Frauen.
Wo sie natürlich auch sagt, also von Restaurantkritiken hat die da nicht gesprochen.
Kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Das ist eine Zeit her, dass ich den Vortrag habe ich damals besucht.
Aber von Restaurantkritik hat die da nichts, war nicht die Rede. Hm.
Okay, mh.
Jetzt müssen wir sagen, das ist hier noch ein Eckpunktepapier,
das heißt da vielleicht ist sie schlau genug, sich da jetzt mal auch dieses
Feedback wirklich durch den Kopf gehen zu lassen.
Vielleicht wird der tatsächliche Gesetzestext dann noch besser.
Ja, dann haben wir wieder noch eine schlechte Nachricht. Wir haben ja hier immer
wieder über das Verschwörhaus gesprochen in Ulm.
Da hat die, gab's ein Hackerspace-Verschwörhaus, da hat die Stadt Ulm diese
ehrenamtliche Community,
haben sich irgendwie getrennt und da haben die Stadt gesagt,
ach übrigens, denn die Marke ist unsere.
Und jetzt hat das Landgericht Stuttgart der Klage der Stadt Ulm um die Markenrechte
am Begriff Verschwörhaus stattgegeben in allen Punkten.
Die Stadt hatte nämlich eben gegen den Verein Verschwörhaus geklagt,
die halt irgendwie ehrenamtlich dort tätig waren und ja, und hat halt ihren
eigenen Namen, den sie sich selber gegeben haben, weggeklagt.
Geil. So und sie dürfen im geschäftlichen Verkehr nicht ohne Zustimmung der
Klägerin das Zeichen Verschwörungs verwenden.
Insbesondere nicht als Vereinsname führen oder zur Kennzeichnung von Dienstleichen
im Bereich der Bildung, Weiterbildung für Social Media Accounts und Websites
benutzen. Weil zur Wiederhandlung droht dem Verein ein Ordnungsgeld von bis
zu 250.000 Euro. So faszinierend,
ey.
Da machst du ehrenamtlich so einen Verein, machst was für die scheiß Stadt und
dann nehmen sie es dir weg und klagen dir deine eigenen Namensrechte weg. Das ist doch wirklich.
Er ist doch wirklich faszinierend.
Die Logik des Gerichts scheint hier schlicht die zu sein, dass ja irgendwie
im Namen Haus ist und Haus würde sich ja dann sozusagen auf den Ort beziehen.
Es ist einfach faszinierend, wie man das so, also wie man, ja.
Ich bin gespannt, wie viel ehrenamtliches Engagement in diesem Bereich in Ulm
sich so in der nächsten Zeit entwickeln wird.
Es gibt ein Thread vom OO, OO, Ed-Verschwörhaus, da wäre ich aber jetzt vorsichtig.
Das Urteil ist doch nicht rechtskräftig, insofern können sie das glaube ich gerade noch machen,
aber in der Urteilsbegründung steht, es könne vor unserer Vereinsgründung 2019
nicht auf einen Rechtsbindungswillen geschlossen werden, um ein Namensrechtsverlangen,
Verschwörhaus sei außerdem eine Etablissementbezeichnung für das Gebäude.
Am Weinhof 9 in Ulm. Das Gericht erkennt einerseits klar unser Engagement an.
Wir hätten mit unserer Arbeit am Weinhof, dem Betrieb von Website und Social-Media-Profilen
jedoch keine Namensrechte für unsere Community erworben, sondern es sei hierdurch
die Marke für die Stadt begründet worden.
Die Stadt kann sich, also das, was sie da gemacht haben,
hat der Stadt erst die Markenrechte gegeben, die Stadt kann sich nun zu einer
vorläufigen Vollstreckung des noch nicht rechtskräftigen Urteils entschließen,
wir müssen dann bereits sehr kurzfristig aufhören, uns Verschwörungs zu nennen,
das beinhaltet diesen Accounts, unsere Website, unsere Gemeinde Zinggifau und viel mehr.
Wie genau es rechtlich weitergeht, wissen wir aktuell noch nicht.
Wir werden das Urteil gemeinsam mit unserer Anwältin diese Woche in Ruhe analysieren
und dann entscheiden, ob und wie wir rechtlich weiter vorgehen werden.
Das Urteil hat für uns eine problematische Signalwirkung.
Digitales Ehrenamt konzentriert sich zunächst oft auf inhaltlich wechselnde
Projekte anstatt auf die Etablierung rechtlicher Strukturen,
wie zum Beispiel einen e.V. oder einen Schutz von Markenrechten.
Im Urteil ist die Rede von fehlendem Rechtsbindungswillen, wobei die Besonderheit
des Ulmer-Projekts Stadtlabor doch gerade darin bestand,
dass die Stadt einen Raum für Civic-Tech-Engagement stellte,
ohne dass dieses sich bereits explizit als e.V. organisiert haben musste.
Wie sollen Communities wie die unsere nun agieren, wenn sie nicht Gefahr laufen
wollen, einem Machtgefälle zu unterliegen, durch das Verwaltungen ehrenamtlicher
Arbeit einseitig für sich reklamieren können?
Wie können sie sicherstellen, dass ihnen nicht die Identität genommen wird?
Egal wie es mit unserem Namen weitergeht, sicher ist jetzt schon,
wir setzen unsere inhaltliche Arbeit fort und werden wie gehabt positiv in die Zukunft arbeiten.
Hoffentlich können wir sehr bald auch wieder mit einem bunten Angebot neue Türen
eröffnen. Das ist ja das andere Ding, dass die ganze Zeit jetzt mit diesem Mist
beschäftigt sind. Also es ist wirklich,
sehr, sehr, sehr, einfach peinlich für die Stadt, ja.
Total.
Das ist auch irgendwie so eine...
Tja mal gucken was ihr mit ihrem Verschwörhaus noch... Also wer sich da sozusagen
auch drin engagieren will in ihrem Verschwörhaus.
So, dann haben wir noch...
Eine Anklage der Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft.
Wir gucken in die anderen Bundesländer und denken alle bekloppt.
Und dann kommt man nochmal, bevor wir den Eindruck haben, dass in Berlin nicht alle bekloppt sind.
Falls irgendjemand ausgerechnet in dieser Woche den Eindruck gewonnen hätte,
in Berlin wären nicht alle bekloppt, könnte ja sein, dass diese Woche jemand
noch nicht den Eindruck hatte, in Berlin wären alle bekloppt.
Drei Wahlgänge?
Mhm.
Und wenn ich mir eins wünschen kann, Tim, ne? Also es ist jetzt schlimm genug
jetzt mit dem Wegner, ne?
Aber können wir dann bitte wenigstens die Franziska Giffey aus dem Bild?
Jo, ich find's einfach okay, dass die jetzt zwei Jahre Zeit haben,
ihre Beklopptheit auch schön öffentlich darstellen lassen zu können.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob das Experiment wirklich so greift.
Wieso nur zwei Jahre?
Na das war doch jetzt sozusagen eine Nachwahl.
Und die gilt dann jetzt nur für zwei Jahre?
Für den Rest der Legislatur ist jetzt keine neue Wahl, sondern es ist ja eine Nachwahl.
Ach irre, das war mir nicht klar.
Von daher, mal gucken, wie sie sich jetzt so darstellen.
Ja, da wird die AfD sich freuen, dass sie jetzt in zwei Jahren schon wieder
einen neuen Bürgermeister wählen dürfen. Also Berlin.
Gibt es jetzt eine Anklage der Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft gegen das Zentrum
für politische Schönheit wegen Fälschung beweiserheblicher Daten?
Nach Paragraph 269 StGB und das ist der Paragraph, der die elektronische Form
der Urkundenfälschung betrifft und beispielsweise bei Phishing-Straftaten zum Tragen kommt.
Also Phishing, gerade gibt es ganz viel DHL Phishing,
schickt dir jemand ein E-Mail, ist ein DHL Logo drin, dann suchst du eine DHL
Seite, gibt es da irgendwas ein, das heißt hier werden der Beweis,
erhebliche Daten gefälscht, hier wird eine Webseite gefälscht,
du wirst in einen falschen Kontext gerissen, das ist Phishing.
Und das ZPS habe also Phishing betrieben und außerdem Amtsanmaßung,
weil sie nämlich den Eindruck hoheitlichen Handelns erweckt haben.
So, jetzt denkst du dir, was habt ihr denn gemacht, Leute? Was habt ihr denn getan?
Ja, die haben eine frei abrufbare Internetseite www.unserewaffen.de veröffentlicht.
Und da haben sie eine vermeintlich vom Bundesamt für den militärischen Abstehendienst
herrührende Ausdoppung einer Belohnung von jeweils 1000 Euro für Hinweise ausgewiesen.
Da ging es nämlich darum, dass bei der Bundeswehr massenhaft Waffen wegkommen.
Das ZPS hat gesagt, wer uns einen Hinweis gibt, wo die sind,
dass wir die wiederkriegen.
Wo sind unsere Waffen? Jetzt Meldungen machen. Kann man hier in der Wayback-Maschine anschauen,
weil hier oben das Logo des militärischen Abschirmdienstes ist,
also das Ritterkreuz oder das Eiserne Kreuz, aber das ist auch die Bundeswehr
und die anderen Nazis haben das auch irgendwie.
Deine Waffe, deine Verantwortung, wo sind unsere Waffen?
Suchen sie mit. Dann haben sie die Waffen abgebildet und haben gesagt, 225 Gramm C4 sind weg.
48.000 Schuss Munition, Heckler & Koch G3, 11 Stück von weg und ich sag mal.
Geht ja noch.
Ja also das ist schon eine ganz schöne Sammlung.
Sprengschnur, Waffenrohr.
So das ist halt nett nett, es ist halt eine ZPS-Aktion, 8 Signalpistolen, okay die sind 5p8.
So und natürlich machen sie dann, das ist ja auch noch sehr schön,
dass sie sagen, Extremisten sind keine Kameraden, was ich schön finde,
dass sie jetzt sagen, informiere den MAD, wenn irgendwelche Nazis hier Knarren
zocken beim Bund, alles ganz nett eigentlich.
Also letzten Endes eine Webseite, wie man sie sich gewünscht hätte.
Richtig, die sind da einfach mal in Vorleistung getreten und kriegen jetzt am
Ende dafür eine Ermittlung,
wenn ich mich recht erinnere, da eben auch Hausdurchsuchung in dem Kontext.
Vielleicht wäre es schöner, wenn man die Zeit mal da rein investieren würde,
die verschwundenen Waffen zu suchen.
Aber es ist halt einfacher, die Künstler hier an der Stelle fertig zu machen.
Also auch das wieder wirklich faszinierend.
Absatz 3 des Paragrafen enthält eine Regelung zur Strafmilderung.
Danach kann das Gericht von einer Bestrafung absehen oder eine geringere Strafe
verhängen, wenn der Täter lediglich eine Urkunde fälscht oder gebraucht,
die nur eine unerhebliche Tatsache bescheinigt und wenn der Schaden,
der durch die Fälschung entsteht, gering ist.
Das wäre hier vielleicht mal ganz gut.
Da sollte man durchaus mal schauen, ob das nicht vielleicht passt,
ja ansonsten Urkundenfälschung.
So dann wären wir bei den Terminen.
Oha.
Warte vielleicht haben wir ja Termine.
Mit Musik?
Können wir mit Musik machen.
Es wurde sich beschwert über die Musik.
Wie sowas gefällt was, die ist entweder zu laut oder zu leise,
da haben die Leute recht.
Ja, also machen wir ohne Musik.
Ohne Musik?
Dann machen wir mal gucken wie das so ist. Könnt ihr dazu mal kommentieren.
Sonst gibt's doch keine Musik. Ja wenn sich die Nachbarn beschweren,
dass es zu laut ist, die Party.
Warte machst du falsch. In der letzten Sendung erwähnt, die Ausstellung in Bonn
Deutschland Digital, da hab ich erwähnt, dass ich da mal...
Hast du ausführlich darüber berichtet, dass du da die wichtigste Person warst?
Nee, die wichtigste Person war ich nicht. Die wichtigste Person ist mir nämlich
jetzt wieder eingefallen, war, ganz schnell, ich such den Namen raus.
Ein gewisser Herr Pridlaff?
Nee, du warst ja nicht da.
Achso, du warst von den Besuchern oder von denen die da ausgestellt werden.
Eberhard von Faber. Der hat nämlich seinen selbstgebauten Computer da ausgestellt,
der Eigenbau-Computer, hier hab ich sogar ein Foto mitgebracht.
Das ist da sein, der hatte ich letztes mal erzählt, der in der DDR da sich seinen
eigenen Computer gebastelt hat aus irgendwie Einzelteilen.
Also zu mir war da jetzt nix oder was? Hä?
Ne?
Komisch.
Deswegen war ja auch jetzt nur wichtigste Person in der Ausstellung. Achso, ok.
Dort, das ist diese Ausstellung in Bonn und der C4, nicht der C4 den das ZPS
sucht, sondern der, Nicht das C4, sondern der C4.
Der Chaos Computer Club Cologne macht dort ein Krypto-Café im Open Space. Das ist am 21.
Mai, 13 bis 16 Uhr.
Zu Themen der Daten- und Computersicherheit eine Beratung im Open Space.
Im Atelier sind Besucherinnen und Besucher herzlich zum Krypto-Café eingeladen,
ihre Endgeräte unter fachkundiger Anleitung von Krypto-Engeln sicher für die
Nutzung im Netz zu machen.
Da kann man also dann in Bonn den Chaos Computer Club Köln,
ich finde ohne Musik, weiß ich nicht, aber ok Link ist in den Shownuts und dann
gibt es in Tübingen, ist das das wo dieser Palme ist?
Streitbar, definitiv.
Oder soll man es lassen, Tübingen?
Naja, macht auf jeden Fall Welle, das muss man eben lassen.
Ja, der kennt ja aber genug Leute, die Welle machen.
Egal.
Der Chaos-Treff Tübingen veranstaltet am 17. Juni 2013 den zweiten Tübinger
Tag der digitalen Freiheit. übrigens 13 und 23.
Sag es. Sag es nicht. Beides Zahlen. Also es ist nicht der Tag der digitalen
Freiheit, es ist der Tübinger Tag der digitalen Freiheit.
Ja genau, das ist schon, also geht nicht über die Stadtgrenzen hinaus.
Also der Tübinger Tag der digitalen Freiheit,
geplant mit Vorträgen, Workshops, Assemblies zum Thema wie digitale Freiheitsrechte,
freie Software, Fediverse, Künstliche Intelligenz, Digitale Kunst und Kultur
und es gibt unterschiedliche Bands und DJs, die da spielen.
Und dann gibt's noch Makerspace und so weiter. Achso ne, zusammen mit Shed,
ich weiß nicht wie man das ausspricht, Shedhallen.
Heißt das wirklich so? Ja.
Da hätte ich nochmal fragen müssen.
Shed-Halle. S-H-I-D-Halle. Heißt tatsächlich so.
Ja.
Shed-Halle.
Keine Ahnung.
Warum nicht?
Gibt es in Berlin auch. In Berlin gibt es auch eine Shed-Halle.
Wirklich? Ja.
Hinten an einer Lepastraße gibt es eine Shed-Halle. Was ist denn eine Shed-Halle?
Das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, was eine Shed-Halle ist. Also,
Chet Gipity sagt, eine Chethalle ist eine große offene Halle,
die typischerweise für industrielle, gewerbliche oder landwirtschaftliche Zwecke genutzt wird.
Die Bezeichnung Chet kommt von dem englischen Wort für Schuppen oder Halle.
Eine Chethalle zeichnet sich mit ihrer geräumigen, offenen Bauweise und ihrer
modularen Konstruktion aus, die eine flexible Nutzung des Innenraums ermöglicht.
Also wenn Chat schon Halle heißt und Halle heißt Halle, dann heißt es Halle Halle.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Höre ich oder?
Okay, ja.
Könnt ihr noch mehr darüber erzählen, aber das reicht jetzt vielleicht auch
nicht mehr. Bin ich auf jeden Fall, Shethalle, darf ich das sagen? Scheiß Wort.
Also Shethalle, sorry, also da habt ihr euch echt, also Shethalle,
wer kommt denn auf so ein Quatsch? Shethalle.
Es gibt überall welche.
Schuppenhalle.
In Tübingen gibt's ne Shethalle, in Zürich gibt's ne Shethalle, in Berlin.
Du das ist ein Erfolgskonzept, das ist einfach ein Modellprojekt.
Das ist ein Verstöß gegen ästhetische Regeln der Wortbildung.
Ja also finde ich jetzt auch.
Aber ihr könnt trotzdem da hingehen, es ist immerhin gibt's halt Tage.
Warte mal in der Chat-Halle, warte mal im Gebäude, was echt scheiße heißt.
So geht's doch auch mal in Ordnung.
Genau und in Tübingen wird das ausgerechnet Teilnahmeskostens bis zum 28.
April, oh Leute ihr wisst nicht wie man Deadlines zieht, bis zum 28.
April, aber zur Not auch später, kann man seine Ideen für eigene Beiträge einreichen.
Ich hab so eine Vermutung wie viele Einreichungen ihr am 28.
April habt, aber das ist dann euer Problem.
Wir sind ja nicht das einzige Outlet.
Aber guck mal hier, Tag der digitalen Freiheit, Tübingen, Städthalle,
17. Juni. Das Event. Ja, also schöne Webseite.
Das stimmt.
Und kann man mitmachen. Für Leute die in Tübingen sind sicherlich eine willkommene
Abwechslung. ehemaliger Schlachthof.
Ja aber der benennt das Ding um, Shit Halle geht gar,
nicht, was kommt als nächstes, Townstadt?
Townhouse bauen die hier.
Townhouse sagt ja was aus, aber Townstadt, also nimmst du das englische Wort
und das deutsche Wort und baust das zusammen und machst ein neues deutsches
Wort daraus. Was soll das?
Weißt du was ähnlich doof ist, finde ich? Der Begriff Fittinge.
Fittinge? Was ist das denn?
Fittinge ist der Plural von Fitting.
So ein mathematisches Fitting oder was?
Nee, guck mal hier, ich hab mir letztens Airline Schiene gekauft und hier das sind Fitting.
Also Dinge die halt was fitten.
Achso, ein Bauteil das in der Sanitär, Heizung oder Klimatechnik sowie der Industrie
verwendet wird, um rohe Schläuche und andere Leitungselemente miteinander zu
verbinden, abzuzweigen oder abzuschließen.
So und der deutsche Plural ist eben ein Fitting, zwei Fittinge.
Okay, das geht gar nicht.
Ne, das geht auch nicht. Und vor allem, weißt du was richtig schlimm ist?
Das ist wie Fit-Anpassung.
Wenn du in der Chat-Halle Fittinge hast, dann sind da Chat-Hallen Fittinge.
Oh Gott, das fehlt doch wieder zu Kommentaren.
So fertig, Ende der Sendung, ich will nach Hause, ich hab keine Lust mehr.
Genau, Leute, aber wenn ihr das jetzt kommentiert, dann verfolgen wir euch,
dann sperren wir eure Accounts, dann zeigen wir euch wegen digitaler Gewalt,
dann belangen wir euch nach BGB wegen digitaler Gewalt, dann gibt es einfach
direkt Schadensersatz.
So sieht's aus. Ok.
Super. Ach ist doch nicht alles so schlecht. Da bin ich doch total lustig.
Noch was zu lachen gehabt.
Leute, das war's von uns erstmal wieder. Und wir hören uns dann bald wieder, denke ich.
Bis dahin.
Tschau tschau.